many parts of the world remain under
lockdown in the battle to contain Kovan
19 the global death toll has passed
100,000 with nearly 2 million reported
cases the World Health Organization
warns that lifting any lockdown measures
too early could lead to a deadly
resurgence in infections Holly Williams
is in Istanbul Turkey the latest country
to restrict the movement of its citizens
Holly good morning good morning well the
government here in Turkey announced very
late last night that 31 cities around
the country would go into a 48-hour
curfew beginning at midnight effectively
banning most people from leaving their
homes and allowing only pharmacies
bakeries and essential services like
hospitals to remain open as a result
people rush to supermarkets to stock up
and although things remained orderly in
places some panicked shoppers ignored
social distancing advice and there were
even multiple reports of fights breaking
out this morning here in Estonia here in
Istanbul the streets are eerily quiet
and security forces have been deployed
to enforce the curfew now in the United
Kingdom the death toll now stands at
almost nine thousand and yesterday 980
people died surpassing the worst daily
figures even from places like Italy and
Spain one rare tree is that the Prime
Minister Boris Johnson who was treated
in an ICU this week is now apparently up
and walking again and reportedly filling
his time by doing Sudoku puzzles now for
people around the world who've been
living under lockdown in some cases for
weeks now the big question is how and
when life might go back to normal
well Austria has announced that it is
allowing some shops to reopen next week
and Denmark says that if its infection
rate remains stable it will reopen
elementary schools mid month Michelle
well that would be good some good news
but tsuyoku deficit who definitely might
go to to Holly thank you so much